here on the show we love to shine a
light on people
who are working hard to help other
people
you guys have been working tirelessly to
support frontline
workers thank you luca and isabella i
saw this headline
about a 17 year old carly deary
and her mission to keep our furry
friends our families
safe in an emergency she has spent
every weekend for the last four years
driving for uber in order to buy
supplies
gifts clothes for her students
for years kenya congress has been
quietly funneling
uh-huh cute her profits right back to
her customers and her community please
welcome kenya
hi hello hello
how is everyone this morning please take
a look at
dc's teacher of the year alejandro diaz
granados who has made it his personal
mission to help his students succeed
while learning from home today's drew
gooder is
serena jones from miami florida who's
making headlines for her organization
village fridge and she came up with a
unique way to provide
free meals to miami locals who have been
struggling through the pandemic
inside the refrigerators we make sure we
include water canned goods sandwiches
bread potatoes
frozen foods that can be microwaved we
take a percentage of our profit a day
and we put it to the side
and at the end of the day we'll see who
needs help or maybe it's a big bill
and we'll wait until the end of the week
to help someone
i have to be there this is my call to be
there for kids
i'm like no child should ever wake up
not have christmas presents because i've
been there before
i'm so excited to talk to her um renee
are you there i am how are you
what have you guys been dealing with so
when the pandemic first started in march
um you know it was a huge challenge to
make sure that students were still
receiving a high quality education
were able to understand um you know how
many students didn't have access to
internet and student students then have
access to devices
[Music]
oh my gosh serena you're so beautiful
inside and out while so many of us
want to try to figure out what we can do
you are out there
doing it i love that your
do-gooding um or drew gooding of course
but it's all about you
kenya thank you really is a success
right now i mean i i can't
even believe our hearts bleed for these
pets these pets are
our family you're the voice for these
pets and you are the one putting it into
action
and keeping them safe and you are a true
hero
all that we want to do on this show is
recognize what's happening around us
we just wanted to tell you that our
friends at omaha steaks heard about what
you're doing
and they want to send you ten thousand
dollars
worth of single serve protein meals and
steak snacks carly
the people at paw print oxygen were so
excited to hear about your story that
they're donating
ten thousand dollars worth of pet
oxygen mask and rescue kit to your car
oh my gosh that's amazing they're a
small company whose founders aren't much
older than you
because you're all young game changers
saving the world i know
that you take everything that you get
and you give it away so we would like to
cover this 2500
contribution for you and then also you
need to do something for yourself when
you take care of everybody
else ross tell her what she's won okay
you ready for this
we're gonna send you on a seven night
all-inclusive trip for two with spa
treatments to the
royalton punta cana resort and casino
it's the perfect escape for the ultimate
vacation
we actually reached out to um the
asus um which is a leading tech company
driven by innovation and quality
products
for more than 30 years and they heard
your incredible story
and they are giving us enough asus
chromebooks
for every single student and teacher at
ayton elementary
that's amazing i like can't even fathom
this this is crazy
meeting drew barrymore getting computers
for our school
computers for these i'm at a loss higher
school bp
wants to give you this five thousand
dollar gift card that can be used at bp
and amico stations and
then we wanted to get something else for
your kids so today
kid pick the number one clothing
subscription box for kids
wants to donate another five thousand
dollars worth of winter clothing
for you and your students i haven't done
anything
i haven't done anything special you know
what renee
i don't think any of us are gonna even
come close to measuring
up to what you do so i i mean
you're a teacher for a reason because
you're teaching a lot more than your
students
thank you guys so much i mean
do you really think that what you do is
like the bare minimum and not
special that's what you're supposed to
do
this is what you're supposed to do i
just want everyone to be like you and
you are our teacher renee
i can't thank you enough shine a light
on people
who are being such extraordinary human
[Music]
beings
you